[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ever worked too long didn't read tell me
your success stories please okay that's
the 200 read this is this is the uh the
actual question my husband and I are
splitting but he tells me that he sees
us getting back together at some point
that he still loves me I guess we're
taking a break but with no unhealthy
promises like I'll definitely get back
with you has taking a break or
separating like this ever actually
worked I'd be so interested to hear of
these successes as well as the failures
please and thank you okay so the tldr
answer to the question is no it's not
gonna work well we'll break that down a
little bit but let me first start by
saying that your husband does not love
you again that's a hard pill to swallow
but um but he doesn't love you and if if
you're married to someone and you're
saying I'm going to separate from you I
don't want to be around you anymore that
is by definition you not loving that
person I mean if that's if that counts
as you loving them then the word love
just doesn't mean anything and of course
that's part of the problem here is that
the word love has come to mean
absolutely not nothing for most people
what is love love is a vague emotional
uh experience it's a it's a feeling and
not even a really clear feeling but it's
kind of a vague feeling and so he says
oh well yeah I still you know I still
feel like I'm I feel okay thoughts about
you and I'm gonna go do my own thing but
uh you know I want uh I don't hate you I
don't I don't actively dislike you
that's what love isn't that's not really
love
as far as separations go
um it's something like 70 to 80 percent
you can check me on that but it is
certainly the vast majority of
separations end in divorce vast majority
do so this is not going to be a good
strategy for saving your marriage
which is not surprising like why is that
why is it that the vast majority of
separations lead to divorce because
first of all that's what a separation is
it's a kind of it's the it is a lead-up
to divorce it's the trial run for
divorce but the bigger issue here is
you're not dealing with whatever the
problem is whatever the reason is
whatever has led
to the two of you wanting to separate
you cannot deal with that by separating
okay because it's a problem it is a it
is a a both of you problem it's a
problem in your relationship so between
the two of you there is something going
on there
and if you separate so that now there's
miles and houses between you
you're not gonna be able to work on that
thing whatever it is the response
usually is that well uh the separation
is great because
I I can work on myself you know I need
to I need to spend some time thinking
about and working on myself
the reason that you're in this situation
to begin with is that you spend too much
time focusing on yourself
every single divorce what lies at the
bottom of it is selfishness it's just
that he's so self-centered it might be
selfishness on the on the part of both
Partners often it is it may be mainly on
the on on the part of one it manifests
itself in different ways we often hear
that well it's it's money that leads to
divorce it's Affairs that leads it for
so yeah these things but these are
manifestations of selfishness or the
most selfish thing of all that you can
do in a relationship is cheap that's
that's selfishness you're thinking about
yourself you're thinking about what you
want you're thinking about satisfying
your own
urges right
and you're putting that above the
relationship and if your solution is to
go live separately and focus even more
on yourselves
then that will almost certainly lead to
divorce now does that mean that there
should never be a separation in a
marriage no I think that I if you want
to call it a marital Separation can be a
very good idea but here's what I mean by
that
great for like a couple hours okay so it
doesn't move away doesn't mean live
Separate Lives it just means like if
you're having an argument if it's a very
tense time and you're and you're getting
angry if you die can I have all of you
nothing I've been dead since the minute
I said I do the moment you feel that
anger kind of reached a tipping point
where now you're yelling or you're
tempted to start yelling then every
single time it's a good idea to separate
yourself from the situation go to a
different room for like an hour
or like go out and get a coffee while
today's coffee often comes with hints of
soy and social justice Black Rifle
delivers an entirely different
experience bold strong and delicious
Black Rifle coffee is the coffee that I
choose to get me through the day Black
Rifle coffee company is veteran founded
and operated their mission is to help
service members successfully transition
from the military into entrepreneurship
they provide assistance to Veterans who
seek to launch businesses of their own
with the goal of helping more companies
like Black Rifle become a reality as for
the coffee itself while Black Rifle
sources the most exotic Rose from around
the globe all coffee is roasted here in
the US by veteran-led teams of coffee
experts Black Rifle has all the best
Brewing gear thermoses mugs apparel
designed all for folks who love country
and coffee so you can go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code walls for
10 off coffee Coffee Gear apparel or
when you sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com promo code walls for 10
off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee here's one
that was sent to me this is from Tick
Tock which is always a Bastion of bad
advice don't get married
till you drop
and then just back okay so it says have
sex till you drop and then just buy a
house don't get married do that uh and I
I love this and the reason that I love
it is because it's just quintessential
bad relationship advice so you are you
are inevitably when you're in a
relationship with someone
you don't want to get married well
either there are two two possibilities
one possibility is that the relationship
will just dissolve very quickly because
there's no end point in mind there's no
reason there's no reason for this
relationship to exist it's a trip with
no with no kind of destination in mind
where are we going I don't know and uh
people aren't going to stay on that trip
for very long the other possible
endpoint is that it dissolves later on
in the in the meantime it begins to
emulate marriage it start you start
taking on a lot of the external
landmarks of of marriage but without the
marriage there you move in you buy a
house you have you share a mortgage you
do all these things which it looks a lot
like marriage but it is
what's the advantage to emulating
marriage taking on sort of the disguise
of Marriage playing marriage
without actually having the marriage
what's the advantage there there isn't
one it's only disadvantage because now
you have
all of the same kinds of entanglements
that you end up with in a marriage but
you don't have the marriage
so you have all these things but but you
don't have the marriage which means you
don't have the glue you don't have the
commitment and all you've bought
yourself in that case is vulnerability
just makes you more vulnerable now it's
true obviously unfortunately that in
many cases people can get married and
they do all these things and they get
houses and they have kids and then they
still split up that obviously happens
far too often but there is nothing
preventing that there is no kind of wall
there is no protection put in place at
all if you don't even have the marriage
to begin with insane you don't want to
get married what you're saying to the
other person is I don't want that
commitment I want to leave this door
open so that I can leave at any time if
you're sitting down eating dinner maybe
on a bad date with someone and and
you're sitting and eating dinner with
them and you see them they keep kind of
looking to the side they're looking at
the exit they're like looking over there
look because they're just they're not
really that into it and they're kind of
looking for a way out they want to be
they want to get out of the conversation
that's what the entire relationship
becomes
your relationship with someone who's
constantly looking at the exit it's like
they're in the relationship but they're
always they've got one eye there and
they're ready to leave at any moment but
because you've started to take on sort
of the form of a marriage uh now you
have made that more and more complicated
well this is just a small taste of what
you could be getting every episode new
segments more advice all the societal
cures that you could ask for and some
that you definitely aren't asking for
sign up now to become a full member of
the sweet baby gang and of the daily
wire and we'll see you on the member
block
what is love but a feeling of soaring
above on a cloud